it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gonna keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when it was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do it
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kit
we're out come on baby
let's do this yeah
we got heated man we got a little heated
because we're talking
mma there's a lot of ufc news
and the number one news source in the
world i heard is the new thick boy fight
news just dropped our first episode
you're getting that daily daily the boys
are working hard back you're getting
that daily i don't think they realize
how much work it is they're swamped 24
7. that's a lot of work i'm running an
apple sweatshop coming up
okay there'll be no lunch breaks today
because we got a chopped chop oh now
your back's gonna hurt cause you're
gonna have to pick up daddy's diet coke
what you do is you do this you get a
giant [ __ ] hamster you know what
would you nope you got a giant hamster
tube that you feed it at water but
instead you put like put a protein
like paste in there and they just like
decided just come up and go
yep and you keep working yep you got a
suck break i mean they we i keep them
powered they get all the rain body feel
they can handle all right well brain
body we get energy drinks coffee all
right i need food gotta get something
covered gotta get some food some nice
pillows but just making it quick you
just gotta blend everything together and
put it in that hamster tube
and oh i'm running a hamster shop or you
have one of those big things that you
those big you it's like a giant
injection but it's used to baste like a
turkey oh you're doing pregnant horses
yes and you fill that with your own
concoction of protein like a protein
paste
mark what mark
what would you put okay
we have to work for one year in a
[ __ ] factory the sweatshirt you get
no breaks you gotta you gotta you gotta
feed us but you want us an optimal
health what do you put in that [ __ ]
protein shake you have
15 seconds i'm counting i'm timing uh
high quality carbohydrates like brown
rice you better get cereal you can use
some rice
uh just the highest quality meat out
meat and potatoes and brown rice
and just blend it up
oatmeal
here's a great breakfast for people like
if you don't have any time
mix whey protein and oatmeal together in
a blender with some ice
it tastes really good it does look good
maybe what's that a little sweet and
little yeah you can make it like you
know did you cook the oatmeal first
obviously no dry oatmeal it gives it a
consistency that kind of plays like a
cinnamon toast crunch flavor type
protein with
oatmeal and almond milk well i don't
like i think you need the almond milk in
there but because also the the grains
float to the bottom now so you got a
drink of water yeah you can't have it
sit there you gotta blend it you know me
i chuck it in four seconds yeah so so
whey protein powder whey protein isolate
probably yeah but that's that observes
really quickly so you might want to
blend in some casein protein hey hold on
hey guys i'm enjoying this this is so
funny
i don't want to say we've lost all
listeners a few real quick hold on yeah
the guys aren't going to do that okay
that was the best shake right that was
the bit but
you know yeah yeah well you know one
thing i've been meaning to do this is
order um
pre-cooked chicken for the like the
chicken
i'm bored already not oh come on you
[ __ ] up yeah i know i know yeah
i just was talking about the ingredients
you're doing on his own time though you
know it's like protein well they in that
in that show alone the [ __ ] uh
survivalist basically he he lives on
seaweed and clams and the truth is if
you eat if you eat seaweed and clams you
can attain perfect health
but you know what they don't tell you
about i hope they don't no because
shellfish has all like it's kind of a
superfood like oysters or if you just
eat that that's all you eat literally a
lot of the native americans basically
lived on that oh yeah because the
epitome of health they they were i mean
they were a lot healthier but but you
can live literally on just shellfish you
can and and seaweed you'd have to eat so
much shellfish actually uh one butter
clam
has uh the equivalent of one egg and
protein yeah yeah
one egg
starving yeah but eat one clam you could
eat 10 clams easily easily but doing it
every day
crazy you're nuts and these guys said
that the guys smell but they don't teach
you you get you've learned survival it's
awesome and you learn how to build a
fire you learn how to find water you
learn how to forest for food you know
what they don't teach you they don't
teach you how to [ __ ]
do nothing all day long because that's
what you're going to do because there's
nothing to do besides that yeah i'm sure
because after a while the
view and like nature just like all right
after about a week like okay not a week
couple days that's a you're like all
right got it yeah even on vacation after
three days like okay there's the ocean
yeah there's the sand yeah got it
now you're on a tent and it's raining
when i went hunting with rogan there was
like hey guys is kale force winds which
means like winds between 40 and 60 miles
an hour gale force winds guys so uh
we're gonna have to be in our tents
bunker down you're gonna bunker down and
it might be about 13 hours i was like
hold on
hold on is this at night through the
night
so it's day so so then we and it's
raining so what you do is you you pitch
your tent you find a place that's kind
of soft good luck with that and you're
in the middle of nowhere and then you
pitch your tent and you just
sit in your tent all alone
for no i don't want to do that no
no you don't i ate all my food
i got your boy you guys just chilled and
talked
no you don't talk because you're not
together brennan oh you're in your own
town yeah you're in your own tent so i
tried to read but how much can you talk
after a certain amount of time how long
can you live if you're with somebody for
too long it's just like oh my god we
won't be able to hear this just no yeah
just showing you guys like what can you
do man yeah that was a great time right
there oh my god yeah yeah
miserable that's a pretty view but after
a while you're just like all right
all day long saw no animals saw zero
ends
saw zero animals that's a tough gig yeah
not a good time you're still all up on a
loan's nuts huh yeah still obsessed
i don't know why i don't want to get
through it
it takes a long time because i've got to
watch commercials because on the disney
channel you have to watch commercials
commercials on the disney no not disney
i mean history channel history channel
yeah but they have a loan on do they
have a loan on netflix now one season
the last season oh they don't have all
the seasons on there no you know netflix
that lost a million subscribers i know
yeah they're going they said it's going
to trend back the other way but
is it they linked up with microsoft to
offer a cheaper virgin version because
they're losing so many subscribers yeah
the content has been great i wanted you
know stranger things though that was
[ __ ] lit so they have a couple of
things that are great but narcos
stranger things you put a lot of stuff
out there that that doesn't do us so
well so it's like a ton of garbage yeah
yeah a few good specials yeah this
stuff's just trash on there man that's
right you're searching through like [ __ ]
this i know
i know i was bummed out strange things
and and i was watching this interview
with the duffy brothers who wrote it and
i thought this was interesting because
you've seen stranger things right and so
11 and like the guy that they call papa
you know he's doing experiments on mind
control and uh the
creator of the show the duffy brothers
one of them was saying that that was all
rooted in real
uh history
from the mk ultra problem
and then so i went down this rabbit hole
looking up mk ultra where they were
using psychedelics so mk ultra was um
this scientist this old school scientist
thought with enough lsd right that was
government uh funded the government
bought literally all the lsd they could
get their hands on back in the day you
know the 60s 250 000 in lsd which they
said was the the all the lsd in america
about 250 000
and then they would run experiments on
people a lot of prisoners a lot of you
know people that were poor they'd run
these experiments on them with lsd and
his thinking was
is because they thought russia and the
nazis were doing it already where they
could use mind control so if you had a
set of beliefs if they gave you enough
lsd and pumped all this propaganda in
you they could clear whatever base you
start from and then insert their ideas
but really then and then they were also
working on mind control because they
thought the russians figured out how to
use mind control and also they thought
they were curious if the mine could work
kind of how levin does yeah it's
ridiculous but what they found out is
they did a lot of evil [ __ ] and what
happens is
they gave these people so much lsd it
really wired them the wrong way so if
you look at the people that went through
that mk ultra let me give you a few
whitey bulger do you know that i did not
whitey bulger from black mass i i heard
a guy named
the new england cartel or uh charles
manson was heavy in the empty true yeah
oh yeah so this is all true so why do
you bulge your eyes mighty bulger
charles manson ready for this the una
bomber ted consent kazinsky went through
it
but the only thing about that's a little
dicey with ted
when they were interviewing when he got
caught you know they uh someone brought
up when he was at harvard they ran all
these mind control [ __ ] on him the mk
ultra [ __ ] and uh his mom said to his
brother because his brother had a
a suspicion that maybe it was his
brother who's the unabomber you know
who's the biggest man 50 million dollars
in taxpayers money and his brother read
the note i was like god that sounds a
lot like my brother
so he went and asked his mom i was like
there's no way if i can take it do you
believe that mom like there's no way and
he brought up those um the mk ultra
stuff when he was at harvard and she
goes it's not that she was she was that
that didn't help but it's not that she's
like your brother's always had an issue
like he has a sociopathic type of way
and she goes i can tell you what
happened when he was a very young
he got some illness
and for whatever reason they put him in
this hospital he was young
young like six months old eight months
old but enough where you can kind of
remember but you know you at six eight
months old you really need your mom your
parents but they put them in this
hospitals hospital for whatever reason
had this program where they kept the kid
for months and the parents could only
visit once or twice a week for an hour
so he thought his parents left him oh my
gosh she goes he started off the for
those first six months sweet kid
sweet kid we get him back after that he
never forgave us and his he just his
brain was wired different he came back
and he was very aggressive mean
very direct like
it just cut the cord from caring about
people what the [ __ ] man and she's like
that's when he changed and she goes but
mk ultra definitely [ __ ] him up didn't
help but he's always had issues ever
since that day since we got back from
the hospital we didn't recognize him and
his and his brother was like jesus
christ but yeah mk ultra it's not so's
man but basically after all the
experiment with lsd all that [ __ ] even
the guy doing it was taking lsd but they
gave whitey bulger
for a year straight when he was in
prison for a year she was in prison for
a year straight he ran the mk ultra
program a year straight lsd every single
day
and he started to go nuts
when he got out of prison
he told his boys i'm gonna find that
doctor i'm gonna murder him with my bare
hands and that was his goal but then you
know he was on the run and just couldn't
get there
because they are doing new
experimentation with uh psychedelics so
remember we did micro doses remember we
did
dmt
so you know what ayahuasca does do you
know what the difference is
it's really interesting ayahuasca is dmt
but the ayahuasca stops your body
from breaking it down so you kind of
stay in that state for like four hours
oh instead five hours yeah so it's a is
is it more like a concentrated dmt i it
i i think it's an elongated trip so you
oh you can have a trip that'll last four
or five hours six hours and we did which
one do you we did dmt security
so when you do it it's like so intense
for three minutes
can you imagine that going forward oh no
not for me sir not for me
i i don't want anything that's gonna
make me do that brendan do you mind
recapping what your dmt experience was
like hey b let's take a little break
take a break dude because what if i told
you yeah there was a company called
helix sleep and all you do is take a
short quiz takes you two minutes and
then they pair you up with a mattress
that's built for your skinny body so if
i'm a side sleep promise tummy sleeper
i'm a back sleeper i'm a heavy sleeper
i'm a hot sleeper they got everything i
need yeah but you show light doesn't
matter does it but everybody else there
you spend a third of your life in bed i
want to show lights though right it
doesn't matter well no because daddy
sleep on bamboo daddy sleeps on a helix
and it's a beautiful mattress it's my
favorite oh yeah i sleep hard oh yeah oh
i sleep hard yeah so if you're looking
for a mattress you take the quiz you
order the matches it shows up to your
door ship for free you don't even need
to go to the mattress store ever again
don't go away the number one best
overall madness mattress pick in 2020 by
gq and wired magazine it's been
recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving sleep but forget all that take
the quiz yes it's got a 10 year warranty
try it for 100 nights risk-free 100
nights if you don't like it they'll pick
it up for you but don't worry about it i
get to you're going to love it helix is
offering the final kid army 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
the listeners and viewers at
helixsleep.com
fighter that's hewicksleep.com
fighter for 200 off all mattresses there
it is
maybe no one likes waiting on a paycheck
especially when he got bills dude it
stresses you out that's why you get your
paycheck two days early with direct
deposits you're talking about chime and
thank god for chime dude chime is more
than just about getting paid early it's
also an award-winning mobile app
checking account debit card optional
savings accounts we got you guys covered
man so what are you waiting for
hopefully not your paycheck getting
started with chime today applying for a
free account takes less than two minutes
two you got two minutes to save money
and get paid early go to chime dot com
slash fighter chime dot com slash finder
banking services and debt card provided
by the bank corp bank or stride bank n a
members fdic this is the real important
part guys listen to this early access to
direct deposit funds depends on payer
yes chimed.com fighter
i don't want anything that's gonna make
me do that brendan do you mind recapping
what your dmt experience was like
uh it was so fun i was laughing so loud
uh aubry was like dude you're you got a
pipe you're so loud and i thought i was
in there for like three hours but he was
like that was 45 seconds yeah and i was
shot into this like warm
like
cool like almost heaven like in the
clouds were all gold i was bouncing off
the clouds just laughing i was like so
loved in there it's fun man i could not
stop laughing yeah yeah it's a good time
yeah that's good me and brian [ __ ]
each other
which is weird but also fun
do you like the two brian i uh
you were laughing too i loved it yeah we
kept wanting to go back under but aubrey
was like man i'll take it easy dude yeah
but he wants to turn to whitey bulger
yeah i'm interested in the ayahuasca
experience yeah i'm interested in uh in
doing more mushrooms under like
supervision yeah i want to just see i'm
interested in uh
i because there's new science around it
and it's interesting it's interesting
for sure i don't i think i'm too old to
have things fundamentally rewire my
brain because i think i've i've
done a good job of understanding what's
important but
i i don't know i want to if they can
create new neurons and stuff yeah i
think i think it could help anyone can i
just think it's incredible the guys with
ct and all like ptsd they say it creates
new neurons so you never know you might
come back and you're just gay that
that's that's the goal and that's the
goal to be able to finally let you out
when i come back i want to be straight
up [ __ ] crazy yeah i'm [ __ ] crazy i come
and i go hey i totally feel normal i'm
crazy i'm going to be honest all i see
with you guys is three [ __ ] i don't
even see your face and then we'd be at
the comic con like you see bryan lee
like dude dmt is just gay he's down like
he's on santa monica boulevard with a
shirt tied up in a knot yeah but no i
mean i don't mean like is that guy gay i
mean you're flamboyant
i'll pay you guys to suck your dick
you're just a random driving by in your
[ __ ] cadillac this mouth is for hire
only it costs you nothing yeah like
you're just a straight free lot lizard
just sucking off the truck drivers we're
like where's brian yeah so the
interstate dude he's at that truck that
trip made him i'm like how much is he
making nothing he doesn't take their
money
oh i think it's interesting
psilocybin yeah um actually has shown to
be almost eighty percent effective in
curing smoking that's [ __ ] great with
one with one session done through and
it's only smoking or can it cure other
well it's it's had enormous effects on
in many cases with ptsd enormous effects
ptsd has been you know it i don't know
it just expands the realm of what's
possible you know what my thing is with
that with the mk ultra thing like whitey
bulger
charles manson ted kaczynski all those
guys was it the mk ultra and the lsd or
are they just
terrible human beings we go and they
just happen to be in that program yes
but they are the thank you three of the
most infamous criminals of all time
they do have that in common or
do they also have
they were born sociopaths and just they
were gonna be criminals where they did
that or not so so here's my here's my
thought on it watch this brandon i'm
doing experiments
with uh lsd do you want to sign up do
you have anybody have time absolutely
not okay you don't have any time to sign
up because you're busy having a life yes
now the kind of person that says sign me
up for a year of experience oh
they didn't have a choice
well they were in prison yeah yeah no
they haven't choice
no i think they have to sign consent
forms
uh no no no no no no not back then
that's that's the problem i see like
like like whitey bulger didn't want to
do it for a year straight that's why you
want to murder the guy yeah but i would
say it's one of the
misconceptions about like the charles
manson story they go the lsd made him
crazy they're also doing amphetamines
around the clock and that's it's like if
you were to attribute it to something
well hold on hold on listen he's not
going to make you well hold on if you
know anything about charles manson first
of all hold on first of all
his his mom
gave him up his mom offered to trade him
for and for eight ounces of a cold beer
when he was a kid in front of him at a
bar yeah so he and then he grew up in
foster homes in the foster homes he was
raped and then in order to fight back he
raped another kid at knifepoint so he
grew up like hustling like in the dark
for sure his childhood was worst
he called the hallways of always he grew
up in reform schools that kid was
destroyed that kid was destroyed from
the jump and then with ted kaczynski
he's a bit of a shame because you know
like
we'll say like like as a genius no no
ted when ted consists he was 16 he took
uh an iq test and it was so high he had
a full-ride scholarship to harvard at
16. he almost won a field medal in 16th
like a field medal that's that's the
equivalent of the the [ __ ] nobel
prize in science what you want to hear
something else interesting about ted
kaczynski this found it very fascinating
so you know obviously he grew his mom
said he was a social pathway he
volunteered when he came when he came he
did yeah he did at harvard yes at
harvard he didn't he explains why he did
that but manson and the other and uh and
i know whitey bulge didn't have a choice
wow a lot of people didn't have a choice
and some would do it just because for
free drugs for god's sakes but um with
ted kaczynski his thing's interesting
because again his mom says your
sociopath when he came back from the
hospital
um and he was very smart but his his his
brother said one of the big biggest
turning points too is he was never good
with the ladies he was kind of vance a
little bit he was very like to himself
he knew kaczynski yeah he was very to
himself he was a introvert
but he he liked women clearly and he
would take shots at women you know and
they would turn him down then he met one
girl who was into him and then they went
on three dates and finally she's like i
think we're better off as friends and
then that's when his brother knew his
brother had a problem because he was
like dude i'm gonna hide in her car and
kill her and he's like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about he's like yeah i'm
just joking and his brother's like well
that's weird so his big thing he kept
getting turned down by women so much so
he wanted to know what because he never
had sex no nothing
so he was so curious about women there
was such a mystery to him he actually
signed up this is real he actually
signed up to go through and have an
operation become a woman and the day of
it he turned it was like ah [ __ ] yeah
that was that was because wow the
unimodal so he agreed to be part of the
program this is this is manson or bulger
bulger uh called mk ultimate in exchange
for a lighter sentence a yeah but i
guarantee the interim a year of lsd yeah
no
no no with the dude well once
you think the wardens can like oh you're
not feeling good today let's go ahead
and skip the lsd today yeah no bubba we
got research together some work you know
what even the guy who was running the
experiment i found out
he found out that you uh you you can't
manipulate somebody through drugs and
clear their memory but you can [ __ ] them
up big time to to make them
schizophrenic and make them delusional
you can do that yeah but you can't erase
their memory and put in a new one no and
also there's no mind control as far as
the stranger things like picking up a
can they thought they could do they
thought russians were doing that that's
why they launched this program
and it [ __ ] it's really not so we
have no idea how or why psychedelics
work but that that is the new frontier
of research well a lot of people think
when you see like the prism we take
psychedelics like that's the
next life like that's a lot of people
think that's
you know
that's how we know there's another world
out there so we see those weird [ __ ]
prisms but it's very beautiful right
when you look at that prism and you're
on dmt you're like for five seconds and
then you're in this [ __ ] k hole of
i had i had a life-changing and profound
trick take it easy
for four or four hours on mushrooms for
real when i was 22.
i took a did i ever tell you this i
never took i told you i think yeah you
stole the story i took i took a four
hour shower yeah yeah and i i i kept
seeing myself from the side
i kept seeing myself and i was like my
profile is terrible and i hate myself
and i i what i did was i went i can't
lie about anything anymore like i can't
lie to myself i can't
[ __ ] i can't
i can't
be in relations that i want to be into i
don't i can't be lying to my parents i
can't be lying to myself was this really
profound
just like when you're young you're
confused so you you you'll do you'll say
what i mean by that is it was like this
i was like okay you're a cutie back then
i was a cutie pie like if you do a bunch
of shrooms now you know no i think
you're finally except your hair is
terrible my hair's circled but but it
was more like this i was like i
i will be a banker because that's what
my dad is oh god and i was being a good
boy and then i was like i can't do
anything
that i that that i'm that you don't want
to do yeah yeah that's not in your
heart yeah you're doing it for to please
other people yeah so you started robbing
banks i started robbing banks
but that was life-changing yeah this is
going to sound weird but i remember i my
father had a big influence on me i was
afraid of him i was dead yeah i was
terrified of my dad i wanted to be like
him he was the ultimate authority figure
and i i [ __ ] took him out he thought
it was weird because i go hey i want to
talk to you and he was like huh
all right so we went and i said
i i don't i got to stop trying to be
like you
he was like oh and i go i'm just not
like you man did you tell me you did a
bunch of shrooms i did
that didn't go well with your pocket it
didn't you i know your dad if he was
like no i don't think i told you was he
like what i don't think i told him no my
dad wouldn't cause he wouldn't
understand no not at all yeah but what i
did say was i said i need to stop trying
to be like you and i'm not sure where
i'm going but i think i have to try to
be an actor and you're cool with it
right he's supportive yeah if you were
told him took but he he he was cool that
the way you'd be cool with like he was
cool that the way you'd be cool with
tiger coming up to you and saying dad
i'm trans oh yeah and you'd go you go
you go
i love you very much and where would it
yeah but all the plans you have for him
to be those other things
you see me heartbreaking you're still
going to love the [ __ ] you're going to
accept it but it's deep down like i
could see it with my father i i i i
could see him kind of go
ugh like it was like it's like when you
get broken up with by somebody and they
go it's all good whatever's good for you
and then it then they leave three years
later you're still [ __ ] still
yeah no i think with a dad and you're
dead too it's like
for your dad it's scary it's scary even
now my son's only [ __ ] six and i had
another two-year-old
mark saw boston tate how [ __ ] cute is
boston with that shaped head oh yeah
it's like a 300 baby he looks great he's
talking nonstop he's the cutest [ __ ]
kid in the world yeah but um
your dad can contri has some power and
control over you being successful in
banking
that's his world
connections it's also predictable like
there's also like something linear about
that's what i'm saying like he can be
like well if you because i did this so
if you do this this and this you're
gonna get here yeah so you don't need to
venture off and do all this bull just do
this and this we know you're going to
have that's right
a good life here very scary when you're
childish
i'm going to do this yeah when you're
kidding me and you guys have no idea
about it when your kid decides to do the
the un take the road less traveled the
unconventional road man it's really
[ __ ] scary for your parents because
like that you're no control your kid
goes i'm different i'm gonna do this
thing and as a parent first of all you
have no idea how to help them navigate
that path you have no influence there
it's like my dad also grew up really
poor so for him the idea of you being a
[ __ ] actor is like dude you got to
make a living
he didn't have the luxury of going uh
you know you gotta pay your rent he's
also not in the business right so to him
it's like he also knew but he's also
like you're not clint eastwood bubba
well but he said to me i remember he
goes look i'm just looking at the
numbers because i'm just looking at i'm
looking at the number of movie stars do
you want to be a movie star you want to
be an i tell my dad i would tell my dad
though i'd be like daddy but
he goes he goes he goes he goes
he looked at it and he goes
you want to be a movie star you know i
go yeah he goes like tom hanks i
remember i was like yeah and he goes so
tom he goes that's great he said
you have a better chance i just want you
to look at the numbers you have a better
chance of being a u.s senator
if you look at the numbers 100 there are
100 senators yeah but like to be a movie
star is there are seven or eight like it
was really interesting and i was like i
get it i i would it's also if in that
business like there's different levels
to it like obviously there's tom hanks
but there's also the guy that you know
that he's in all these successful shows
that he's not a main character but you
know him of course that guy's doing
really well of course you know of course
but it's up because he's not in the
business and there's no control my son
last night dad just tell me what you're
gonna do i'm gonna do it as far as crazy
he's like tell me what job should i have
one he might just like that and i told
him i said bubba dude you're six you
don't need to that's the best part you
don't need to decide you only be focused
on anything you do everything dude and
then you have a long time to have to
decide dude it was when i go mid-20s you
know even then i'm such a pushover i'll
probably float all your bills until you
figure it out well
the other thing is that you're it's
really interesting because when your son
idolizes
when when a son idolizes his father even
if the father isn't a suppressive
character
it's it's like still a big oak tree he's
got to get out from under to get his own
sunshine and sometimes you've got to
kind of like like you said kind of push
him you know because
i'm
my son i've never loved anything like
that in my life
you know it's [ __ ] weird right yeah
and and if my son comes to me when he's
30 and says i need all the money i'm
giving him all the [ __ ] money if he
needs my kidney i'm giving him my kidney
when i watch intervention and you see
those parents you start crying if people
don't have kids they're like what the
[ __ ] mom quit giving the good their
daughter the son money for drugs and
it's like i'm telling you you don't
understand it i can barely tell my kid
no if he wants a toy or candy i know let
alone if they're 25 strung out on drugs
if they don't get it they're going to
the streets
no but i come you you look at that show
intervention different when you have
kids that's my favorite you understand
it that's my favorite jordan peterson
quote when he was talking about he was
going through hell he was going through
hell his wife had terminal cancer and
and he his daughter has uh rheumatoid
arthritis yes and that's why the
carnivore and he was he had they put him
on this colonopin or some weird drug
that he couldn't get over and he was
they put him in an induced coma see he
was coming out of it man and he you
could see oh and by the way he was only
eating meat still is because it was the
only way to deal with all the stuff so
he's literally going through this insane
chaos and and uh this [ __ ] i i watch
it all the time because i just never get
tired of it and i've played it here
before but he goes you know will the
people ask what is the anecdote to
suffering
and i suppose it would be comfort
but but comforts what a mother acts out
when she swallows a baby
and a better anecdote to suffering is an
adventure to excellence
try to be the best you can be using all
your talents along that those lines
right but that and he said the courage
of a mother or a father is to facilitate
that not only that suffering to [ __ ]
but also to encourage us and meaning hey
get out of here and also take chances
but it's like go away go go out there
and then the kids figure it out kid goes
but dad it's dangerous out there and
it's like okay but he's like yeah no
kidding but guess what it's more
dangerous if you stay here with me yeah
and he button it with this he goes you
go out there you might lose your body
you stay with me
you'll lose your soul
oh and i was like mother [ __ ] it's so
true yeah but then also i'll watch bates
motel and they're like my girl's like
that mom that son are crazy but also
i get it like she won't let them do
anything they sleep together yeah like
not sexually they sleep together he's
24. well i get my danny my girl
[Music]
basically
makes fun of me because i still baby my
son yeah i don't know i don't know how
you thought i do too i don't give a [ __ ]
i love him
i don't know i mean i love my daughter
too but my daughter's more independent
she's 14. barely needs me yeah she'll be
barely needs me she's gonna be fine yeah
yeah it's dicey
i just love hanging out with them too
you know i don't know the only ones the
kids in here
and chin are like quit giving those kids
candy
candy
yeah no i didn't my my parents were
never very strict and um
you know
it's david you mean like they gave you
freedom do what the [ __ ] you want
they did give me quite a bit of freedom
my dad your hair expresses that
right it's a while it's true yeah i'm
well i was gonna say the only time i
remember my dad really getting pissed
like i remember i was failing at
calculus class my senior high school and
he came out of the football field to
like grab me off to like bring me to the
you know tutor or whatever
but like other than like he wouldn't
express public anger like that over you
know like was your dad your hero
for sure i looked up to him a lot and um
you know uh
again we've talked about some of the
things we're like things that were
annoying to me as a younger kid like him
stopping people like with said ignatius
sweatshirts on and like figuring out the
connections i'm like oh my god but now
it's like that's really cool to have
yeah
that instinct to connect to people um
and also as a really good storyteller so
like my recollection of like family
dinners are like you know get the whole
family together i'm in the room and i
hear his like booming voice like telling
some story making everybody yeah it's
annoying but you're the exact same like
mark's a really good storyteller mark's
voice is super i mean
when we come to the airport you can hear
a mark from a mile a good voice he's
loud thank you a strong but you'd also
define mark as a i would define him as
like a free spirit like mark to wild yes
like you should have been born in the an
artist i think
artistic artistic yeah and his own
i appreciate it so i was going to say
that parenting style like you know
there's arguments against it or not but
i don't think you're you know your kid's
not going to begrudge you that i think
every kid responds differently some kids
they they find do really well with
discipline and rigidity and artistic
kids don't
you know some kids don't do well with a
stick they do way better with a carrot
right
i was one of those kids i don't know
what i was actually i i don't even know
what the [ __ ] i was but some kids like
you know you probably did really well
with a set schedule and a grind you know
not some kids are too sensitive for that
yeah you know they they don't want to
you know it's a little bit too much
practice four hours a day no matter what
because it gives them directions
i might want a
just can't have the kid just really
nilly like oh you don't want to go to
school that's fine [ __ ] that well then
you're [ __ ] dude your mom let you do
whatever you want and you're seven do
you ever see that experiment they did
with the
it's fascinating they took uh
three-year-olds
three-year-olds and they would take a
marshmallow
put it right there and they'd go now
listen
you can eat that marshmallow now but if
you wait ten minutes we'll give you two
marshmallows
and the kids that are able to put
delayed gratification
were better at delayed gratification if
they could put that they could if they
could control themselves for ten minutes
they went on to be much more successful
in life
makes all the sense you need some
structure yeah there's also you have
those friends growing up where their
parents were like their best friends
they're like they're the parents in high
school are like once you guys come over
i'll take you know put your car keys in
the bowl here and i'll buy you guys beer
it's like oh hi
being so cool you know it's always weird
those parents were always yeah yeah yeah
like the kid didn't really respect them
you know yeah they're like more like a
bro they're like friends yeah they're
friends if you're trying to please your
kids i think that's what i versus when i
hear you like you oh it's hard to say no
that's airing on this side of like
the kids know that you love them 100
what if they didn't i don't know what
it's like to grow up and feel like do my
parents actually love me that sounds
really good when you get whitey bulger
and charles manson and yeah
yeah all those [ __ ] savages so yeah
because you know what they say about
nightstalker i mean sammy the bull
guarano said i was dyslexic and so what
happened to me is bullied right as a kid
they told me i was dumb yeah and then i
didn't give a [ __ ] because they told me
not only did they tell me i was dumb
they'd ask me to spell cat and laugh i'd
hear the girls giggling and i couldn't
do it yep and and and the humiliation
said he was like i'm never going to
school i'm going to the street and i'm
going to [ __ ] punch people in the
face
like it it just changes you you never
because they say that people who have a
very low like they're not afraid you
know bank robbers race car drivers
there's a there's a personality that
just doesn't get us nervous they say
that that those kinds of those kinds of
personalities if they don't have really
loving supportive parents they'll get
that juice over here
channel it professional like legal ways
or if they run with the wrong crew
you have very good bank robbers correct
and they don't get caught for a very
long time correct that's what it is it's
interesting right yep that's why i
thought dexter was such a good movie uh
tv
loved him because because the his dad
finds out he's a serial killer and goes
that that you like it you get off on
killing things huh he goes yeah and he
goes all right
you're gonna you're gonna get you're
gonna kill i'm gonna let you kill but
you're gonna kill serial killers well he
goes not circular she's like we got to
control it yeah he's like you're going
to kill bad guys because these bad guys
are cheating the system getting off
they're killing people and doing like
three years or getting away with it
with some [ __ ] evidence he's like
those are actual bad guys so if you're
gonna kill you're gonna be like robin
hood you'll be like batman and you just
you just gotta be smart about it god
just go it was good can't feel anything
it was great i should be mad right i
should be mad that this guy's bullying
my girlfriend and i should he's like i
guess maybe i'll kill him but then he
loved his son
i didn't i didn't get to that part oh he
had a son yeah yeah that's so weird he's
done in the new the newest season which
it was the season finale you don't let
me ruin it for you right no
okay let me see what it's for sure the
season five okay right his son don't
tell me please he had to well he had to
he
yeah i don't want a room for you can i
ask you if he had to fake his own death
to get away because there was so much
heat on miami so he moves to like
montana or some [ __ ] and he starts a new
life new name there and his son actually
seeks him out and finds him and he's
like 18 now yeah
it's so interesting i thought the new
season
the first three with the same rider yeah
some of the best tv of all time yeah
after three it gets a little rough it
does this newest one that there's a
newest one yeah on show time it came out
a few months ago oh [ __ ] the newest one
which it it's not even the real dexter
uh season eight i thought you were an
actor oh yeah all the same cast i
thought season and the sisters in it too
as a ghost i think season one two three
so the best tv ever
uh four through seven was sloppy because
they lost their head rider to twilight
she moved she was like oh say less i'm
gonna go write for twilight and make all
the money so they had new writers so it
wasn't as good and then season eight is
right up there one through three what's
this diagnosis
you had cancer i remember that that's
why they took such a long break
between uh i think like seasons four
through seven there was long breaks
he had cancer and they beat and came
back what kind of cancer um
[ __ ]
you you know he's in a band he's saying
he like tortures
[Music]
but he had it while he was shooting
damn
like season four and five six he had it
then it was dealing with like chemo and
[ __ ] beast that's not fun yeah super
beast that's not fun yeah i love dexter
oh listen dude oh my god oh my god i've
been waiting for this let's take a break
because we have to break the news well i
gotta take a break break the news we're
gonna be this weekend because i'm gonna
be in wisconsin oh dude i'm being in san
diego and i'm in san diego this thursday
friday saturday so if you're in the
wisconsin area of the san diego area you
want to see some comedy you come either
to my show with milwaukee rack up those
miles go see brian in wisconsin fly from
there and go to san diego while you're
doing that watch best stuff watch best
stuff on on youtube.com briancomedy yeah
do it man all right the breaking news we
have for you guys listen business wars
is a podcast from wandery that shares
entertaining eye-popping stories behind
the world's greatest business rivalries
tell me about gucci and versus louis
vuitton tell me about you know i'm a
fashion guy dude the bitter feud between
these two icons gucci and louis vuitton
there's no better way to show off your
money and status than by wearing a gucci
belt or louis vuitton shoes you got
family feuds boardroom battles runway
backstage they both started as basically
luggage companies and then people went
oh we like this design say less we make
all the money but we're going to get a
nasty feeling it was a war yes listen to
gucci versus louis vuitton from business
wars on apple podcast amazon music or
listen one week early an ad free by
joining wondering plus in apple podcast
or the one app enjoy um can we talk a
little can we change the subject oh
there's a little film fight news yeah
yeah because i just heard something
there's two on there's two there's okay
nate diaz
announced in september let's you want to
talk about that first sure bring it what
do you got
hey do you like it b do you want a bad
eye i hate it
why
i like nate diaz that's why do you not
like hamza
i don't want nate diaz fighting a guy
who's in who should be two-way classes
ahead of him and also i mean i mean who
is the newest blood and a [ __ ]
monster and nate diaz is uh more in the
twilight of his career i i i want him to
see i want to see nate make all the
money but i don't want to see nate take
that kind of damage here's what i'm
hoping
nate
and he
you know that's not going to happen but
i think see i see i don't think dong
yuron when they first announced i was
like jesus christ pay doesn't pay to
talk [ __ ] to the boss because what i
think happened is nate kept poking the
bull kept poking the bull and dana goes
oh you want you want to fight you
you want to play this game dude you have
one fighting contract here's literally
the worst possible match up for you
here's hamza you're going to be a plus
eleven hundred dollars
it isn't it it isn't when i first
initially heard i was like oh my god
they're [ __ ] ideas
part of me and how social media is
social media is like 15 years in ufc
this how you repay guy just because he
wants to leave and do his thing and i
was like yeah they're right i thought
about it too it's like dana's like all
right dude we're trying this guy fight
we do got to build the business
if hamza absolutely destroys nate builds
the myth of hamza to be fair too though
hamza showed holes in the gilbert burns
fight where if he fought the same way
against nate he's not gonna win but i
think he's gonna
i really think he's gonna his camp he's
from a great camp they're gonna go all
right dude this isn't gonna be an
all-out brawl you're gonna use your
[ __ ] brain because you're a monster
and fight smart
so if it's a improved hamzat
it's gonna be a long night for an eight
by long i mean short yeah but if because
nate's so goddamn tough
nate's so [ __ ] tough a long night
he's gonna be a long night i don't want
to see him take that kind of damage i
know nate's tough i know nate can take
all the damage i don't want to see him
get that kind of damage from a monster
that comes out who's this young
lion who's who's confided 85 and gave
everybody fits 85. but we think that and
i said that too like before we fought
gilbert i'm like he can go to 85 [ __ ] he
can go to 205. nate's a big ass 170.
he's not going to be that bigger than
that nate walks at 190. i know what nate
walks right and nate is big but komzat
is just a different
he's just a different thing he's the
elite new elite i hate he's not he's not
though he's he
he beat gilbert burns bob
you know all that war right still being
short gilbert still being
short
hold on short gilbert burns who's not
known as a striker and beat him in a
straight line burns is he's not striking
explosive is [ __ ] not he's throwing
his head around dude he's not a striker
hold on
gilbert burns is a world-class mission
artist and has more submissions than
knockouts but what got him what got him
to the dance was what
knocking people out no no no no no
bring up his gum to the dance is his
submission game bring up and then as he
evolved he started to knock guys right
that's what i'm saying though but you
know what exciting was he was knocking
dudes out and he hit so hard gilbert
burns yes
look at this
tko punches
tko punches decisions you see see what
i'm saying what got him to the ufc look
at his submissions there's some tkos in
there yeah but look at all a lot of
submissions low submissions then he gets
there because you go to the ground with
him you're in trouble his first thing is
not striking his first thing is
his background is well i'm talking
world-class yes
world-class yeah
and excuse me
he was a jusu
i know him just as juicy coach
striking became secondary so for me with
hamza in that fight for that to be an
all-out brawl again hamzap fought stupid
he won he'd be the number two guy in the
world which is amazing at his ranking
but again you outstruck a guy whose
background is jiu jitsu yeah because if
you do that to
you know the elite strikers there's no
way home that makes it out of that alive
it's just not happening those guys are
too technical
you're going to a brawl with a world
class striker it's going to be a long
night for you
but i think that was a lack of
experience he's going to go back to the
drawing board because he can fight smart
and i would assume he fights smart
against nate diaz because here's the
thing part of me
part of me and i'm a huge hamzap fan and
for the ufc which you know i'm ufc
through and through for the ufc
obviously it's better harms that wins
because nate's gonna right off the
sunset fight jake paul and that's how
this story ends yeah
wouldn't it be funny if nate diaz
submits homs up with a triangle and does
this while he's choking him out they
give him the mic and he
lights up dana and goes [ __ ] you this
was the guy this is you thought he was
going to beat me
how fun would that be
wouldn't that be fun sure and there's a
possibility that could happen
and that's why this is great and
fantasyland i love how you're riding so
hard for nate i really do appreciate it
i love nate diaz but uh i'm just saying
if that harms that who showed up to
fight gilbert burns comes with this i
disagree i disagree he still beats him
he's too big he's too he's just too good
he's not that much bigger dude too good
he's not that much bigger than nate he's
he's not taller than me he's big he's
six too nate's [ __ ] big he's about
five six one no nate's big i've been i
spent i've i've also spent time with him
he's about six one he's big every bit of
190 so does harm's had dude hamster's
not as big as you think
hamzad's about six two hamza looked
enormous too hamzah looked enormous
enormous next gilbert burns because they
have gilderless have five gilbert's not
five no he's not there he's not he's
definitely not uh kobe is definitely 5
11. but uh but [ __ ] um comes out but
isn't there something fun
wouldn't it be cool
if nate were to beat him and ruin the
plan of course what if leon edwards
beats us
what's he do you know the ufc is like
holy [ __ ]
it's fun
it's fun what if alex pierre beats izzy
all this could happen
these aren't long shots i know leon
edwards is going to challenge usman like
you've never seen is that that's a
[ __ ] thing really
yes it's just his striking and leon
edwards is the [ __ ] s this is the
problem he's not the most charismatic
guy he's not going to do a dope promo if
he wins huh
technique why are you saying maybe
toughest fight for rosemont by far what
but by far not named colby kobe's his
toughest matchup stylist and they've had
wrestling because of the wrestling the
the pays the what is leon edwards
wrestling pedigree
you don't have a russian pedigree but
his takedown defense is filthy it's
filled worked at it for seven years
aka seven years josh thompson
josh thompson who's the camp the ak is
like dude you've never seen a striker
like this dude this is the guy who lit
up nate and almost got knocked out yeah
this kevin hold on this is the guy that
destroyed nate yeah for
four rounds
four minutes and 30 seconds then the
last 30 seconds he got wobbled
but that fight there was ten eight
rounds so his his his striking is high
high level high level yeah at the
[ __ ] win he also took down nate quite
a bit and controlled him on the ground
yep so so he fought camaros man before
it took a decision 2014 and seven years
ago
this kid is a [ __ ] savage but
in the entertainment aspect of it he you
know he's not gonna sell tickets for the
ufc if usman loses to leon edwards
nightmare right for the nightmare if
alex pierre beats izzy nightmare
nightmare you mean like you'll speak
english
english what are we doing no i agree and
then nate beats [ __ ] harms
it's a [ __ ] show it becomes a complete
show sign me up have you seen that meme
of that that [ __ ] cartoon like this
there's fire around them and it says i'm
fine that's the ufc
and i'm all for i like chaos in my mind
as well i do too
i do too now the odds are if you're if
you're there that's me right there i'm
fine i think it's dana i think to your
point that's dana right there i think to
your point it's dana saying to nate hey
listen dude you're talking a lot of [ __ ]
do you want to fight here you go that's
what's really going on you'll get paid
there's that but then there's also like
if you're a businessman which it take
all your admiration for nate away take
all that away if you're businessman you
want to build the next young lion yeah
nate has the most die-hard fan base
massive top five people who starts yeah
hamzad is you're saying is the next big
thing and
to all
signs you're right he beat the number
two guy in the world in an all-out war
and was ranked [ __ ] 11 and jumped all
the way to two and beat him yeah so all
signs are pointing that he is the next
guy sure so you want if you want to be
the next guy
you gotta have him take out a legend
this has been their game plan to a t
from day one
young buck takes out the legs isn't
there a bigger legend not a bigger
legend isn't there a more challenging
ledger legend i'm trying to think of who
will be good who at 170 who i would have
said robbie lawler but not after
um you can't do rival no
coming off a loss yep and a knockout too
or like uh
so you look at it though everyone else
you can you do wonder boy one boy's up
there wonder boy he's a legend yeah
but other than that not not really dude
hamza is number three
leon edwards has a date already colby's
suing getting kobe's you know has an
injury that'd be that would be
kobe holmes that for me was the fight
yes but then it must have with colby's
like i'm not ready to go so they went
all right nate wants to fight and said
he's down to death so kobe what he's
he's what's going on with him he's hurt
when he got sucker punched that
apparently something there's some uh
issues
like physical
oh [ __ ] that's not good
that's really so he's not ready for the
abc card so then you're his eye
something happened uh bray
yeah brain in his tooth he knocked out
his teeth and also his brain uh
i hope for colby's take and for
i just hope to god that he's you want a
legend a legend that nobody's gonna
complain about don't tell me hold on
hold on hold on wait can i just ask
about the colby the guy who sucker
punched kobe give him if you want to
make muslim pay there you go give
homsworth
that's the move no you want to
discipline someone discipline muslims
not
nate who's you know do you think that
kobe is saying his brain because he can
sue for more money i hope well he was
saying that he after he got hit he
didn't like trump anymore so people were
like that's whoa
he started yeah he
became liberal
he went woke he got hit so hard
uh
that's not good but i think that feels
like
that feels like what you do say if you
want to make some money i'm dizzy i i
can't sleep uh you know i'm forgetting
things you know all that stuff kobe
makes pretty good money good kobe's a
good
dude i hope he doesn't have a brain
injury is what i'm trying to say
uh i know there's some issues there it's
definitely possible man getting sucker
punched really hard he hit him twice he
did yeah three shots and jorge it's
pretty hard yeah yeah when you're not
bracing i'm a jorge fan i wish you
didn't do that but he just changes them
just yeah it was just like a bunch of
freaking lanes but um
you know it i can see how the public's
like dude this is [ __ ] up it's how you
repeat after 15 years and dan's like a
business run he wants to leave he has
this big name we're trying to sell
tickets on this kid now if you watch him
destroy nate and then think about the
lead up like nate's gonna be talking all
sorts of [ __ ] i don't and i don't think
nate's hate's gonna be direct towards
hamza he's gonna definitely throw his
shots at him but i think he respects
hamzat his hates can be towards dana and
it's
entertaining as [ __ ] i just think it's
[ __ ] up and he's gonna write off in
the sunset but nate believes he can win
i i i i well a fighter like that always
does and that's what makes him great but
i i i think it's funny don't feel sorry
i think it's super i i think it's [ __ ]
up but don't feel bad for nate because
also i just think it's disrespectful but
if you if you're going to leave but if
you're going to leave the ufc and i'm
sure they're willing to play ball with
him with the jake ball fight if you're
gonna do that you gotta walk through
fire you know who you're dealing with
it's dana white right yeah he's very
cutthroat i think he was in that mk
ultra program okay
i don't start any rumors
i understand but you're dealing with a
straight business that's shark and he's
like we got to build the next guy you
want out you're going to walk through
dagestanian
via sweden [ __ ] fire dagestani fire
chest
very similar similar sounds like this
sweden fire yeah but at the end of that
rainbow is jake paul
there you go
although that's not an easy fight either
not engine easy fight no that's not easy
at all take my money
yeah that's
dude nate's making it but here's the you
know he's a prize fighter
between this fight and jake he's making
bank let's just say on the small end 15
million dollars you're excited are you
that much mm-hmm
oh that's a lot but the the the bulk of
it comes from jake he might make you
know i don't know two to three million
here but the rest of it comes from jake
it's jake but but here's him there's a
caveat and this is the chaos
if jake were to lose to hassam jr
that nate fight's not as fun
so hassan don't [ __ ] up my saturday i
think hassan might might like like if he
knocks him out it's just if nate this is
such a challenge for nate he's a balls
for nader jake for jake he's up balls
you know the thing
whenever i talk about fighters if i'm
wrong we get emails yeah and when i was
talking about hassam uh
ruckman jr
when i say he has 100 amateur fights and
he's 12-1 a lot of people like have you
seen his like on like he says he has 100
amateur fights that's what his team told
me has 100 fights so i repeat what his
team says to me sure on the internet i
guess his like amateur records like 12
and 14 it's not as amateur that's that
means it's not for you
and then pro he's 12 and one if you look
at that he's five he's five schmucks
he's fight like really bad guys and then
dana also made a good point he goes
hold on if you're jake why are you
fighting the guy that lost to tommy uh
morrison jr why don't you fight tommy
morrison jr like fight together that one
don't fight against coming off the loss
so thomas tommy morrison jr is a badass
is he is he is he uh i mean he knocked
this guy out you know he knocked him out
bring him up he said he was doing really
well until like the he lost in the
fourth or fifth round but he said he was
doing really well against him for
whatever rounds and he kind of just got
yeah i saw the fight it was a good fight
and then he you know he caught him and
then finished him and
apparently
uh haseem rockman said this i don't
think it's tommy morrison is it yeah
it's his son okay
um uh trey lip caleb his dad kind of
criticized him to hear that where he's
like he's you know
not living up to it he's underachieving
junior yeah because tom morrison is dead
right yeah oh yeah yeah no i was saying
he saw a robber
that went crazy
dude his dad
was so jacked with that mullet that left
hook of his he was uh
18
this is he looks like he's kidding
you know
wow
all right i don't know if this is the
guy either
that's him no that's him he was trey lip
morrison i mean he won against
hassan that's not his record what about
him it's on the record
yeah it's the first one
is it not it's not on there no
weird
what are we missing hold on let me go to
a song james morrison look at that
james morrison
does he have two sons
let me look at hassan's record real
quick
jake paul hospital broken back that was
awesome
it was hilarious though because it
scared me too
so that's him there because i broke my
back james morrison james morrison so if
you click on that
oh come on i know can you continue with
google
oh hold on oh there there pops up
oh [ __ ] sex this is jay morrison writer
singer he's all over spotify james
mackenzie morrison here we go
just bring up pictures let me see what
it looks like one sec 19-0 was 17
knockouts
so that's dana's point like fight that
guy he just beat the guy why would you
try to get him off a loss you're playing
also jake has six fights yeah and this
guy's a real fighter i mean he's still a
real boxer
you know he looks a lot like holy [ __ ]
if he does dad's body his dad in his
prime was bodied
dad probably was doing probably got some
help excuse me back then it was so fun
yeah seen that those are oh yeah those
are implants do you know that yeah yeah
he had chest implants really weird
wait did he had he had ages yeah yeah he
had aids yeah you went crazy
yeah dumb mark he had aids of course he
got breast implants tough tough life
dude he was so jacked yeah he was stud
now do we think uh but back then there's
really only two ways to get dates all
right right so
usually they're doing some butt stuff
i'm not going to respond i think you get
some wild nights
needles sir there's only two sir
government
chicken nuggets back then can we talk
about the next
mma issue oh i heard a rumor on the
issue no this is no rumors
no it's confirmed you're going to
confirm it yeah sure akamoto who's like
the mouthpiece of dana white so if so
here's how this works so in the ufc if a
fighter tweets out a fight line up
they get in trouble you're not allowed
to do that so if a fighter tweets
another fighter and oh it's going down
september 3rd whatever
don't hold that as
any worth yeah if brett akamoto tweets
out a matchup in a date
take it to the grave because that he
works for espn which
the ufc works for it used to be ariel
right and ariel had a fallen out with
ufc and dana white now
it's brett akamoto is their
cash cow media guy so brett is if if it
comes from brett you can take it's
happening brett tweeted out
that
sugar shawn o'malley is fighting peter
yan
i don't understand that i don't either i
because i went why would they do that
sugar
i want sugar to now i know they were
talking [ __ ] to each other
that's fine but i want sugar to kind of
be like i want him to be fabulous and
fantastic and keep winning and keep
developing and then and then in two
years
in three years hold on b you're talking
like somebody who cares about sugar show
well you're talking like you have
actually no no no no hold on i'm
actually talking like somebody who
actually cares about the ufc too because
he's a big star so you create like i
hate this i i you you know maybe i hate
this right not and it's not because can
chicken shawn beat peter yan 100
100 not a bad bet 100
my issue is is and i tell us that every
young when five food truck whatever they
ask for advice i say dude it is a
marathon not a sprint right the media
the ufc the fan base is gonna push you
for these huge tough fights right if
you're not getting paid to fight those
huge tough fights and if you don't have
the experience under your belt you are
cutting your career in half and for what
from the pressure from fans and now you
see the comments on what why would they
do this what well hold on because
there's a
hundreds of thousands of people going oh
sugar shawn's never fought anybody you
need to fight somebody so that narrative
he tries to ignore it right and put
sugar's on social he's on [ __ ] twitch
eventually he's like they're right
i need to prove myself no you don't
you're making more money than god
outside the octagon you got [ __ ]
rainbow hair but you let this get to you
and then your coaches go you know what
let's shut them up okay cool
if you remember your manager should be
saying the same [ __ ] i'm saying it is a
marathon not a sprint right let's go
through b let's go through his path he's
fighting peter young in september
all right october 22nd he's always said
he's such a [ __ ]
you know what let's put in your sugar
sean o'malley
and um uh just a reporter going through
it
so let's say best case scenario hey chin
bring up the rankings for me would you
by the way you can replace sugar shawn
within my
brian ortega too i would have brought
him up way slower personally honestly
don't get me started on brian i mean do
not
what happened when i when they announced
one of his fights i called him and
begged him not to think they did
different countries so the same same
different conversation so i'm a reporter
you're you're sugar shauna maddie you
just knocked out peter young right
you're just not pr the number one guy in
the world and you're right number 13
right yeah
we tried giving you the number nine guy
pedro munoz who was a ideal stylistic
matchup for in the top ten sure you beat
peter young hold on you be peter yan
right mm-hmm
what's after that
well
jermaine's a giant named alger man
sterling or because al jermaine and tj
dill shall have to fight or tj dillashaw
now are those guys good at wrestling
i'm just no i'm asking you right are
they good i i
no i'm just asking you dude are they
would you say they're fairly good at
wrestling
only if you think
only if you consider like [ __ ] a
whirlwind a whirlwind banshee like right
so hey b let me ask you this
would you consider algeman sterling have
good wrestling
just a little bit just a little bit yeah
he has good wrestling yeah
peter young out wrestled al germain
yeah multiple times tripped him a lot
with those [ __ ] trips now this last one
he lost and aldrin got his back and you
know he proves how good alterman is
correct so i'll join his pretty good
wrestling tv is pretty good at wrestling
pretty good sugar shawn
phenomenal stand up very hard to train
for awesome good jiu jitsu yeah
after you beat peter yan it does not we
can't protect you anymore i want to see
we this is our last time we can protect
protecting you meaning
you're going to be fighting monsters
pedro munoz is not an easy test peter
young not an easy [ __ ] test but
stylistically we can see how you have
advantages in those fights outside those
two in this current situation we're
living in in the top ten do you know
what i don't see a lot of upside do you
know what i weigh about how long
you know what i would rather see him
fighting for him cory sanhedrin 100
that's what i wanted that's what would
be that's what i told him now
but peter young the former world
champion it's just an as
an assassin a murderer
like high level like striking like just
i don't know man and i'm not saying i'm
not saying sugar can't beat anybody on
the planet it's just that like you said
to your point i want to see this guy be
shine and be a huge
how long for how long i would uh don't
ask me i'm the wrong guy to ask for ten
years probably yeah it'll be a great
career yeah i'm keeping him i'm keeping
him
i'm keeping you on the fast track you
know you got the fastpass
ufc land this is the fastpass in ufc
land and you're gonna go through the
park quicker you'll be exhausted though
no my my issue is that i think sugar
shawn has all the talent in the world
but like with everything in fighting it
takes time to develop that's why boxers
they bring you up slowly you get
developed slowly you you fill those
holes in your game you throw you throw
them to some [ __ ] high-level wrestler
it's like i don't feel like seeing sure
and just so you guys know
sugar shawn
nate diaz hamzat
izzy
jon jones the big names volkanovsky the
big names you know who decides who
fights each other right
no
dana white
he okays that the other the smaller
stuff
hunter campbell and uh the other guys
deal with it but why is the boy fights
personally
so explain this to me what in dana's
mind what is this about
uh
i don't know i
i don't know i don't know b you know me
i'm fully against russian guys and now
yeah
here's my thing my own caveat is sugar
can beat him he can yeah he can sure can
beat anybody if if peter yohn decides to
defend himself a striker all night
you know sugar's longer have some range
dynamic on the feet sure you know if if
peter young team goes uh
we can't prove it because we haven't
seen it really
you know if we want to make this a
grappling match it could be a long night
for sugar
dragon later rounds yeah and then knock
them out that's what i do that's what
and here's the thing i'm not saying
anything that his team doesn't know he
was a world champion for a reason
it could it could be a very easy night
for patreon but sugar is dynamic
and and could not come out my only my
caveat there again where do you where do
we go from here that's what i mean now
we can't protect you now there's no more
bubble dude that's what i mean
and there's a guy he still has
like he still has some shining to do
give him three years to be [ __ ]
fantastic but dude let's the three years
is a bit of a rory santa gonna be a
great fight for him and not even hold on
hold on jose aldo if if you want a young
bike to fight a legend jose aldo would
be a better matchup cory sanderhagen
marlon vera be fun
rob font would be fun correct dominic
cruz older legend dominick there's so
many better picks why wouldn't you just
go to number eight why do we have to
jump all the way to the top well but why
not if you're 13 why not fight a guy who
just won who's been in the ufc for a
while he's a well-known guy he's called
you out why not fight ricky simone why
not put ricky on the map who just had a
phenomenal win over my boy just had a
great win called him out i i think what
they want with sean is like to him to
fight a name but dominic cruz would be
great i mean pick anybody in the [ __ ]
two through [ __ ] 11. i agree two
through 12. i know
but but some had to go on again i don't
know if the mk ultra experiment so but
dana woke up on the wrong side of bed
anyway
oh you know what today is
and hunter campbell's like wow he's out
it's [ __ ] wednesday
and it was [ __ ] wednesday yeah [ __ ]
them yeah all right here's what we're
gonna do hamzat and hunter has he goes
you have your notepad out he's yeah yeah
what do you got hanzo nate diaz
september and he's like what he's like
that's right speaking of [ __ ]
wednesday that sugar shawn always
yapping about fights let's give him
peter young let's get pranked and then
hunter goes gilbert hunter goes hunter
goes hold on hold on the number one guy
in the world he goes yeah
welcome to [ __ ] wednesday
and then i think hunter goes yeah that's
[ __ ] him real quick though and just
spitballing ideas here just want to go
over everything um what if both guys win
and then what if leon edwards be two
spin and then what if
[ __ ] pierra beats izzy dude you know
so it's like
but for the ufc they want sugar to win
do you just have to hope that patty who
fights this weekend who's gonna win i
think in the first round you hope that
in the i [ __ ] i want to protect patty
at all costs you got to hope that
[ __ ] wednesday doesn't leave leak
over in a [ __ ] wednesday next week
and then they announce paddy versus you
know [ __ ] maca chef or some [ __ ] i
don't know what they're going to do
everybody needs to have their head on a
swivel because dana woke up with [ __ ]
wednesday just decided and he just blown
up the company and you know what yeah
daddy's here for it
i mean let's get usman to fight [ __ ]
you know nangano oh let's it my favorite
my favorite reporter goes hey we heard
uh the meeting with nate he said there's
only two viable options it's either izzy
or francis
how did you respond and danny was
what do you say what do you want me to
do
are you serious you're really asking
about this [ __ ] he's going to fight
francis and ghana is there anybody
yeah and he was what do you want me to
say what am i what can i say to that
sensei what do you want me to say that
it's like the only time seeing data like
speeches he goes
what do you want me to do francis and
god deal with insanity here dude i'm
dealing with a [ __ ] search i'm very
surprised that dana would take one of
his biggest stars sure sean o'malley
and not
bring him up slower
what if he asked for it what if he was
like i want to fight it sugar sugar has
already tweeted it peter young okay he
said hey you want to they've taught you
sugar is hilarious it's like you want to
beat me up for a while and peter young
was like smoking weed again uh you know
getting high again or high again yeah
sugar probably said in a russian accent
too the great thing about sugar is he's
very aware uh very self-aware you know
but he's a fighter and he's going to
fight anybody yeah but i i just don't
get it twisted though no
this isn't
this isn't a nate diaz hamza situation
no no no sugar sugar there's no joke
sugar can win this fight
that's not my critique my critique is
what do we do after this it's a marathon
not a sprint yeah and all of a sudden
you've got in the fastpass lane he's in
the monster his squad he's in the middle
you're not fighting
uh 11 through 15 anymore no now once you
be the number one guy you're gonna be
two or three
there's no
again there's no more protection and i
don't know what his con i know he got
paid
but did you get paid at a world-class
level i don't think so but i know if he
becomes champ there's a bump in pay
if sugar strong becomes champ he's gonna
make so much [ __ ] money it's insane
yeah nobody's gonna capitalize more on
being a champion in the trigger show i
think sure patty pimlet right up there
patty has a ways to go
but it's [ __ ] wednesday and if that
leaks over to [ __ ] them wednesday next
week
if i'm a young hungry fan i'm like jesus
christ you're putting money on the uh
market jeff oliveira fight
um i mean i always bet um
yeah i i want to make money so i'm gonna
bet on not because i think he is gonna
win because he can win i'm gonna bet the
dog in charles oliveira because
i've
always questioned his heart and he's
shown multiple times now like in the
michael chandler fight he has heart
and i
i'm i'm not sold on monkey jeff even
though everybody who i respect in the
space they're thinking about
including josh thompson who goes i'm
saying [ __ ] dude wait till he gets
comfortable i'm telling you dude you
haven't seen [ __ ] he's khabib on
steroids he's khabib but he is better
striking his grappling if khabib is an
11. much of a ten
so he think of he was thinking of khabib
his grappling is not as good
but it's the best in the division it's
not the best of all time but it's the
best at 155 right now by far he was and
he hasn't even shown that now add
striking to could be
like
technical wise makeshif is a savage and
he goes in the train room he goes wait
till he gets more comfortable in front
cameras
now i respect the [ __ ] that addressed
them captain aka i love josh phenom
phenomenal podcast wayne he's the best
even that being said i i have to see it
myself i'm not completely sold on mach
chevy i want to see him go through there
[ __ ] broke his ankle yeah and you
just don't beat one guy and i go okay
he's ready for charles oliveira because
i've seen i've seen well technically
he's not but to us he is right miss wait
but
i've seen charles
oliveira go through [ __ ] that michael
chandler first round could have been
10-8 comes
yeah and the fight before that he's
phenomenal yeah
uh so i'm not ready to just disregard
that and be all in a mock job until i
see it myself
so i'm gonna bet on charles oliveira
long long story short and i like money
and he's underdog yeah
now the bet would be much of you if you
think mike jeff can get done you'd bet
that he gets a finish
stuck oh it's a good time to be a ufc
fan though look at all those wins i know
i think we did to justin gaichi dustin
poury michael chandler tony ferguson
kevin lee it's nuts
god damn that's nuts
any great
they say it's [ __ ] wednesday boys
let's let's shake the choice have mercy
wouldn't it be weird to have that power
if you're dana
it's a big response i'm too nice i just
i think you'll be pretty cutthroat i'm
too nice way too nice it's a big
responsibility way too nice
i'd like if like a dc or brian stan ran
the ufc you know i i don't think they
could do it at the level dana does i do
think he's the best to ever do it i
think but you have to be a certain
personality type you know yeah
yeah i think dc and bryant might be a
little too nice
because you gotta make hard decisions
that that uh to me that
the whole thing with sean and peter yan
is a head scratcher i don't know why you
do it
i don't know i don't know what you do
he's one of the brighter stars sean
just such a bright star so yeah you
might his team have been asking for it
you know behind the scenes he's been
like hey all we want we're not gonna
redo the pedro munoz fight we won that
fight like all right dude what do you
want peter i'm talking all this [ __ ] man
all right let's see if peter's into it
that'd be fun the division's kind of
tied up we got everything going we're
still wearing al jermaine tj we got cory
sanderhagen and uh what's what's [ __ ]
his name soto young or
[ __ ] monster you got that tied up
peter is not doing anything let's call
peter what's going on with san hagen
right now he has a fight coming up yeah
who's he tough i hate the fight for him
he's fighting that guy this chinese
youngster who's a [ __ ]
yes really yes and they're trying to get
the song young dung
yeah they're trying to get that guy's a
monster he's a monster
really super savage
i hate this [ __ ] fight and he uh why
do you hate it so much because
think about it you've never heard of him
no okay so you've never heard him but
he's a nightmare
yes he's a [ __ ] nightmare what is
what makes him such a nightmare just
he's good at everything
because he is i mean
he's creating a russian lab
that's why i'm scared of him
yeah i was just looking at mcgregor's
age when he fought mendez for the
interim title
same as shot o'malley right now 27.
yeah for what it's worth i know people
are on different trajectories but i was
just curious i'm like i wonder how old
connor was when he you know when he
yeah you could say connor walked through
the fire i mean kind of you know him
chad mendes but i was on short notice
yeah and chad man is a very good
wrestler and he absolutely annihilated
chad mendes he got taken down but that
was the plan yeah when he got to that i
think they knew chad didn't have time to
train he was going to gas in the first
round so it's just whether that first
round that was still dangerous fight
though yeah
that's prime actually if you don't if
you remember
chad put him on his back and started
beating on him and conor was talking to
him the whole time but they were like
the blue book here is just get him on
his back pick him up and throw him on
his back you know
so that was that was his 20th
professional fight uh mcgregor's against
mendez i wonder what uh pat uh sorry uh
o'malley's at right molly has a lot of
experience not in the uc but you know
rushed to the scene on contender stage
but you'll be surprised how much
experience sugar shot has if you look it
up there's a lot oh yeah
and for sugar maybe maybe maybe he views
things different maybe it's you know i
don't want to keep doing this for 10
years brian and brandon shut the [ __ ] up
yeah how about it for three that's fair
that might be by the way hey what if if
i'm sure what if sugar's defense is here
i'm gonna get to the championship as
fast as possible make all the money i
love them and then right out on twitch
in my merch i sell so much money great
i'll become champion i'm gonna guess i
endorse it for if he goes i'm gonna
stick around and get ct i have too much
[ __ ] to do i'm young i have kids i love
it i have a kit i love it yeah so this
will be his 18th fight
yeah he's not he's not like some newbie
you know he's just killer to the ufc fan
base he's now but he has experience and
you know he has exp he has experience
but not at that level peter young
[ __ ] wednesday
all right what are you doing
all righty
the uh
this one i thought this was hilarious
just the balls on this guy he finds a a
gator
in a playground goes up to it in a bush
i guess he wanted his kids to see he
needed to be able to play so he grabs it
by the tail and yanks it across the
screen as you're about to see
he has to do some [ __ ] for the kids
i don't think you realize how strong
that tail is well i guess not small very
big it's not very big it's still a
[ __ ] wild alligator
you wouldn't do that b i wouldn't do
that no i'm definitely not doing it yeah
i got a that guy's a badass look at him
this guy's about
that's hilarious dude remember i told
you there's like mount lines and [ __ ]
there's mountain siding and the coyotes
in my yard well now they're just
disrespectful now i don't see him they
just dropped the biggest [ __ ] in my yard
like
we're here dude mountain lions or
coyotes we don't know it looks all the
same but they are dropping heavy shits
on my backyard with fur like rabbit fur
in it and [ __ ] yeah like berries and all
that like some wild [ __ ] yeah literally
no pun intended i mean yeah
yeah yeah it's it's some foreign [ __ ]
just all the time though like just so
disrespectful yeah like when where we
play or where the kids play by the pool
it's just insane dude really just [ __ ]
out of all that you do go in the
mountains they're doing the dirt
no no we're gonna [ __ ] where you guys
are at that's [ __ ] up a massive shit's
dude
it's [ __ ] rude man
oh you'll love this be
i take uh
till destroying king's thing but [ __ ] it
i took uh tiger to the home run derby
shout out to our boy uh kevin bay with
three guys tickets i got this jersey
there and got tiger the same one it cost
all the money in the world to get the
jerseys because they don't sell replicas
it's australia you know authentic so
you'll pick a jersey out dude he picks
his jersey i'll pick the same one ring
it up like toss all the man in the world
that's cool
we're in the suite and it's home run
derby it's not the all streams the home
run derby which i've never been to i
wanted to go and win the sw you know the
top suite we're in the suite of the
dodgers owner and the the top agent
baseball he represents all the guys in
the field ball
so we're in that suite and uh we're
right behind home plate and to the right
of me is kevin durant to the left is
magic johnson like it's the who's who my
son's there and i'm like man hey and
there's food he's blowing up chicken
tenders and [ __ ] cookies and [ __ ] so
we sit down and our seats happen to be
the top seat like the front seats of the
suite and you're sitting there
and i'll agree
you know he's not ungrateful he was very
happy to be there after about four
batters yeah he goes uh a little young
from i was bored to be i was like all
right there's gonna keep [ __ ] in the
home run yeah like all right and i said
the entire goes hey
dad um
how much longer
and i go what
was how much longer and i go oh what are
you talking about it was are the doctors
are they gonna play now you go dude i
told you it's in the car it's a home run
derby so they have to hit it into the
crowd points it's timed these are the
best players in the world dude it's a
home run derby it's not a team it's the
national versus american teams the best
players on [ __ ] earth dude and he
goes oh is nano his uncle is is nano out
there
no your uncle no no your uncle coaches
high school dude
these guys make millions of dollars to
hit baseball they're the very best in
the world it was oh okay it was but how
much longer is it going to be in my head
i'm like i'm with you dude it's kind of
i'm bored too yeah so uh i in that but
it kind of triggered me because we're in
a suite there's kevin durant there magic
johnson free food like for a
six-year-old yeah it was fun for me he
doesn't know no kind of triggered me and
i go home you want to go and he goes i
can tell he he realized i was not
thrilled they said that i go what are
you bored
and he goes
no no i'm you know i'm i'm tired
you're tired you don't you never want to
go to bed all of a sudden you're tired
and you're sweet at dodger stadium and
there's no idea dude do you realize you
realize these are the best seats in the
house
and he goes they argue the best seats in
the house and he looks over the railing
is
aren't those better and he's right
behind them
right and he's right but [ __ ] piss me
off and i go [ __ ] no i go dude no no
it's not better it's not and then i get
now you know it's not better that this
[ __ ] you can't see anything there
and they're in the sun they're sweating
their ass off also they don't get free
food and come and go as they please dude
these are the best seats i go look
around look at the beer i go look around
six year olds are hey but i go look
where i go that's [ __ ] that's magic
johnson dude he owns the dodgers your
beloved dog he loves the dodgers beloved
dodgers he's one of the owners dude i
know that guy you know who that is kevin
durant who looks i'm so cool my favorite
player i go [ __ ] kevin right there
dude he's right next to that's kevin
durant he has all the money in the world
he
send me where he wants best player best
basketball player on earth
takes a beat my son goes kevin durant
can hear him he goes that's not lebron
james
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was my office
and i went
i pretended
i knew everybody heard him because
there's no he couldn't oh my everyone
else was quiet watching albert pujols
try to get the next round they were all
you know into it everyone heard him go
that's not lebron this loud that's not
lebron james i went like this be i was
in i wanted to die inside because i know
kevin durant and
whoever he was which was this creature
from a different planet was with him and
his agent i literally went
i stared at the sky
i stared at the sky
because that it's so effective
but he's also right yeah i'm a very
heavy heavy guy tried to say hi to my
son tried to like hey bud like that and
my son when he was three goes no way
you're
way too fat
right right in pete
no way
no way like he's so he's very no way
you're way too fat i was like
no i do
i pretend i don't hear i go
well i left him there i left him there
and i still don't know he's kids today i
gotta get out of here
[Music]
she looked like gru from despicable me
her nose was
out of control right watson
pretends that her nose isn't the scene
of attraction yeah walks in and she's
right behind us and i in my head i'm
like god damn that [ __ ] got a big nose
son goes oh my god dad look at her nose
you know i did
nothing i went like this all right
hey buddy you want a uh you want hot
chocolate i just pretend it never
happens yeah i feel like that's the best
draw attention to it if you try to
correct them like you don't say mean
things to people that are obviously true
right something what are you saying oh i
just went uh right um jesus i go jesus
christ hey uh you want a small hot
chocolate i just pretend it never
happened oh my god but i'm telling you
everyone in that suite heard him go
you're not lebron james i'm like yeah
that's great
yeah kevin what do you got next [ __ ]
sweet here we go
she's so pretty
yeah
she had two aneurysms dang apparently
and she's so pretty that like when i
hear she has less of a brain now i'm
more attracted to her well you might
have a shot as well right yeah all right
hold on you can't see my faults
you can't see that my face is extra slow
after i eat sodium
she's got no repercussions
they're happy i mean she gets older
that's gonna be a disaster yeah
dude i was reading a thing i'm sure it's
not one of the current events i was
trying to think that this actress said
on the set of one of the arnold
schwarzenegger movies that he just he
like i guess in the movie he's on top of
her i used to on break and he just goes
how are you doing she starts stopping
and just farts in her face what just
farts arnold yeah yeah
in her face it's on new york
new york post.com
farted early on in his career i mean 50.
how long
deliberately farting why do i not have
any problem
he was in uh they were shooting believe
it i believe oh no they're shooting a
scene he's into power moves you know
dude that's ultimate empowerment yeah
for awesome but also arnold if even if
i'm gonna actually
fart in my face we're fighting dude i
can't i can't let that go i can't let
the staff know you farmed my face i did
nothing all right so funny thing about
that so she got this is so funny so she
goes i didn't care for him he's a bit
too full of himself all right
he found my face now i fart of course i
do but i don't fart in people's faces he
did it deliberately right my face she
went on to describe uh i was playing
satan's sister and he was killing me so
he had me in a position where i couldn't
escape and lying on the floor and he
just farted
keep going it was not film it was one of
the pauses but i'm forgave him for it uh
in the end of days which i haven't seen
uh the ex-husband of maria shriver
portrayed next cop who has to stop satan
all right uh meanwhile uh shares
he just farted on her when when i was
doing a i was doing yeah but she's
looking for click she has a [ __ ]
podcast then she goes yeah uh leo uh leo
uh leonardo dicaprio he was smelly oh
[ __ ] okay she's just trying to when i
was doing when i was doing death valley
everybody had to run from a well
at least their teeth are white yeah
those teeth look like mine when i was
when i was doing death valley we we all
had to run away from this zombie and we
had to be hiding every everybody all the
whole cast was in a cluster but then you
have to hide for the shot to be done so
they cause cut because you have to keep
the hallway you're staying there so
everybody is like literally
crammed out of the shot yeah out of the
shot in this little corner and my buddy
dallas just goes like this you just hear
me just goes
and just [ __ ] yeah just deliberately
the certain guys like that it's just he
did not for the reason it's [ __ ] like
in i guess maybe because they own it
there's something about it where there's
like
no one really you don't really know
about it it's not even gross girls
aren't laughing oh disgusting everybody
was laughing so hard it dispersed even
the girls yeah it was like a [ __ ]
bomb and everybody was just laughing so
[ __ ] hard because it was such perfect
timing it doesn't give me you didn't
give a [ __ ] now the difference between
that is arnold was like oh you're down
there and and
that's that'd be arnold though he could
give a [ __ ] he just couldn't he could
give a [ __ ] dude oh when arnold broke my
heart he shoots that thing uh during
vaccination goes [ __ ] your freedom
hey
bro
what happened
what [ __ ] your friend [ __ ] your freedom
[ __ ] your freedom come on do it get
vaccinated come on do it
get vaccinated come on do it come on
vaccinating me now do it
[ __ ] your freedom like dude you farting
lady's face where was your freedom
[ __ ] man you'd have to fight right as
a like you think so
you'd have to yeah or just laugh
no way no wait dude hey i would laugh
and then i'd fight back you know we have
to fight yeah like i don't care i can't
have but i can't have the skin leaked
around hollywood that people can fart my
face i do nothing yeah and i'm also
gonna get pink guy arnold you know like
we're fighting that's right sometimes
you get slapped
to the ground you gotta fight back
you can't hold me down and fart on me i
told you my buddy was super strong he
this guy was dating his girlfriend and
he was he's supposed to be his friend
and he grabbed him pulled his pants down
and gave him a spanking against his
[ __ ] truck really hard no one wants
to [ __ ] that guy no
just whack whack whack and he goes i
thought you were my friend [ __ ] the
guy's like
but he's an actor like me yeah my
friend's a little bit like you yeah and
i was like you know what dude you you
stuck your finger in the cage and this
my buddy is from long island got a screw
loose and he's like i'm gonna spank you
can't beat you up because you're too big
i'm gonna give you a spanking and you're
a grown man so [ __ ] you and you're
banging my girlfriend i have to spank
you because you pretended to be my
friend but also took advantage of
banking no one wants to [ __ ] the guy who
got spent put his pants down his
underwear was there and he spanked them
against his imagine that girl and that
guy back at the apartment in new york
and she's like yup did he pull your
pants out and he's like yeah but you
can't believe that he didn't have sex
she's like absolutely not and you know
what they're gonna go see the big guy he
got out and he goes like this he got him
he goes all right let's not make it a
big deal dude okay he goes i'm not hey
yeah the ultimate [ __ ]
diss move dude i think with you if
you're the what you could do with
regular guys is if they were a real dick
to you you just pick them up and you
give them a good squeeze down until they
poo a little bit or pee or you're just
like picking them and just slam them
like wreck-it ralph no i think you could
squeeze them like jesus you could
squeeze them until they passed out or
die yeah you just go
yeah that's humiliating
yeah but then because i can't prove it
yeah but but i can't hold on it should
be a rough going prison no like what's
the big guy in there dude apparently you
you hear the rumor he's hugging a guy
but you're not going to get in prison
and he loved him so much he held him did
that watch it and then i'm running the
tomi's running a train on me dude no no
you're the police officer yeah you just
squeezed me
officer he just squeezed me
you started laughing now yeah do you
have any marks on you
no but i couldn't breathe and he
squeezed me until i passed uh
tell me what happened oh he asked for a
hug give him a hug and now he's saying
like claiming that i [ __ ] held him
too hard
i'd suggest that one of you get a hotel
for the night that's exactly that's it
you're not going to be able to prosecute
that there's nothing you can't do
anything even if you had it on [ __ ]
camera god look at the guy's girlfriend
go you know you have a girlfriend right
like you
so you two get a hotel for the night go
to separate ways ma'am break up with him
right he got held he got hugged too hard
picked me up and he squeezed me towards
he hugged me too hard
okay that's hilarious
but you could break some bones oh yeah
you could [ __ ] somebody up bad that way
you really squeezed for sure yeah i
remember when shane carmen did that to
me i couldn't believe it insane oh yeah
when did he do it like to try to hurt
you just to show you did he pick me up
and i started tapping immediately
yeah and he goes he goes he said that's
40 dude yeah i was shocked because he's
like my height it's like technically on
paper it's like oh these two guys are
roughly a similar height and weight yeah
i'm like oh stronger than brendan yeah
stronger than you right now um
certain weights yeah i mean i'm saying
something squeezing do you think yeah i
could imagine him being because also
just like you're like break his grip
with his i mean
i beat him in the grip contest oh really
yeah yeah yeah as far as like uh stanima
yeah like who could hold the hundred
pounds like farm walk longer i beat him
so what about what about what was he
what were you better at lifting what was
he better at uh i was better at pull-ups
uh he's better at squats and dead lifts
um what was he dead lifting something
yeah
whatever polar bear does
he has that factor to him or like
i don't feel physically intimidated by a
lot of guys you're like there's
something like also his energy you know
well he when he was when i met him he
was 285 and it was all muscle
it was all muscle he's just a scary
looking guy
yeah you know yes
and freakish hands i don't have small
hands
being tight left there's all kinds of
stuff going on all right
okay yeah yeah all right so this is uh
earlier this year well uh
go forward this is in denver jason this
to me jay's like this hilarious because
it was in i think it's no i think this
is in california somewhere in
california visalia navy sailor 29th
boyfriend 25 listen to this
i guess they were stealing bikes all the
time in this neighborhood so they baited
them they left bikes on their lawn and
then when the burglars or the criminals
came to jack their bikes they were
waiting for them
beat the [ __ ] out of them and filmed it
steal bats yeah like that
is there is that and they put it on
youtube which is the part where it's
like i mean that's so dumb can i watch
this i know they don't show the actual
beating they seem like leaving the
apartment or the house but they catch up
when they beat the [ __ ] up yeah it's
hilarious
now i've never dated a girl who'd be
down for this because i was like [ __ ]
you know multiple times too yeah what do
you mean multiple times they did this
multiple times with uh they set up the
bike multiple times they beat up people
multiple times yeah oh they did more
than once yeah
i don't know i've never dated a girl
who'd be open to this i was like hey
here's my plan we're gonna honey
[ __ ] them you know who would be who
would come up with this idea
your wife would i kind of
want to be like can we kill them yeah i
kind of respect
i respect you as criminals but she also
seems like she was the panther
relationship if you look at the mug
shots
he looks so friendly she looks like that
girl who made the fake blood test
company oh yeah a little bit uh
elizabeth holmes yeah i wonder if she
also speaks like us
oh yeah
yeah
khloe kardashian boy the [ __ ] tristan
thomas that [ __ ] dude is tristan
thompson thompson he's unbelievable stud
stud but gets i think he got he's got
two girls pregnant now on her uh
he's fine he strikes again him getting
girls pregnant it's a terrible idea but
i like him dating new women
you talking about the tall handsome guy
with the giant dick and all the money
what hold on you expecting to be
celibate i mean
why is this a new story are they married
or weren't they like you know no they
were never married dating and then he
got one girl she was pregnant he cheated
on her while she was pregnant right so
she was pregnant and he got another girl
pregnant
and then
then he got back together with her and
then he got another girl pregnant that's
what he happened no the girl got
pregnant he's single
no but that's a terrible outfit as a
prisoner no but i think i think he was
dating her wait no no no so he was
dating chloe while you think chloe was
hooking up with this trainer in like
dallas or i got her pregnant dying piece
got her pregnant
said it wasn't his child
but he wasn't with her he was like no we
were we just had a flame she got
pregnant then he's got on to date people
for whatever reason it's a news story
that the big handsome black guy with a
giant dick and all the money
is getting girls yeah i mean that's i
don't get that why these are news
stories yeah
hold on well because she she brought him
back no she didn't both right no well he
she has to because he's the dad to true
their their daughter
she's the dad
right
right but so he's gonna be around for
the kid apparently he's a good dad okay
so he has to be around for the kid you
know but she's still into him but he's
like no she's not into him she's moved
on she's she's dating some like uh
banker now so girls don't like that guy
who's six foot nine and rich as [ __ ] and
handsome and [ __ ] you guys dicks down to
his [ __ ] ankles yeah what i'm sorry
how is this there she is well that's his
baby mama well also like that's that's
her
that's who you are that's that's who's
the ferrari that's who your trainer is
that's who your trainer is that's not
his trainer she's a trainer oh yeah
yeah
oh well yeah i mean i mean she's doing
pull-ups on his dick you know what i'm
saying like that's the only training guy
yeah she's doing weighted pull-ups with
his nuts in her mouth jesus christ yes
she's delicious
you know but it's tristan thompson dude
i don't get how this
oh the famous basketball player but i
mean he's in the dream that's what i
said but that's what i said i was like
if you gonna date a guy like that
with all the options you gotta know it's
real dicey
it's just it's just he's also seven foot
tall and very handsome he has a lot of
money and he's in the new great video
it doesn't look real
it's probably a real nice chin it
doesn't it doesn't look real real but um
how tall is he damn near some foot he's
[ __ ] he's like six ten six eleven
he's that big yes he
pretty good solid player he's canadian
there you go it's a good height good
good good height six foot nine inches
do you want a championship with lebron
and apparently hooked up with uh jordan
woods like that's where it went south
because she was best friends with kylie
it's a [ __ ] storm
yeah
watch the keep up with kardashians b to
get filled in okay yeah what else you
got to talk about all that right
this one here
hold on oh yeah i'm too hot for daycare
yeah holy [ __ ] really the complaint
comes down to this it's the whole
article and what it comes down to is
she's like people give me judgmental
looks when i come to the daycare damn
but how does she come dressed is what i
want to that's a good question but i
guess she runs a successful only fans
with her husband he rails her all the
time adam that guy from no jumper or
whatever that's her husband
wait what oh oh wait is this lena the
plug yeah oh oh dude how did i not how
did i miss that i'm 22. we're making all
the money wait hold on so adam 22's girl
runs a daycare no no
i think
so i guess she goes to the daycare and
she was complaining about judgmental
looks from these from the other women
that the women sort of like reject her
or shun her well that's their the mom's
own insecurities like the rest of those
mom's probably warlocked and then you've
got adam 22's girl whatever name is love
i'm trying to he's a big podcaster good
guy he's also a porn star too i think
i guess he so what he does is he invites
porn stars on his show and they will air
it live on their only fans and like
patreon and then him and his wife will
[ __ ] the porn star it's a brand new idea
and then he manages a lot of only found
pancreas jesus and that's his wife
yeah well she's outstanding
yeah
you know all right
our heart goes out to her you know the
other moms are worried that um i think
some of these moms think i'm going to
strip and start having sex with their
husbands right there if they don't watch
my every move and their mind's kind of
perverted sexual beasts i want to sleep
with anything that moves it's the mom's
own insecurities yeah or they're just
it depends on what she's wearing when
she shows up women are hard on each
other oh yeah you got a pretty gal who
walks in
women are
that they they women love to destroy
reputations they're not gonna they're
not physically aggressive but they'll
[ __ ] your reputation social security i
might say
this one
correct he's set to testify so just a
little follow-up from last week's uh
yeah last episode's current event is
that he's set to testify now we knew
that he denied the allegations and
accused of a mental illness but we are
going to see
ricky go on zoom for the trial in puerto
rico
and uh defend his honor
he's going to talk to the judge and say
like no no no he's got it twisted this
dude made up this whole relationship in
his head
i would never
i didn't
he's crazy i just want to put this
behind me
okay all right
um okay buddy i'm feeling better about
ricky martin
you think he's gonna be good
i think you know the more i thought
about like it's funny how we're
attracted to these headlines where it's
like oh my god ricky martin you know
incest whatever you automatically
believe it because i'm stupid but like
guilty by social media yeah that's my
friend about it yeah yeah
no i tried it
right yeah
after like going through you know what
my friends went through and now i always
question everything yeah it should yeah
yeah i should you just realize more
people sure reaction and even obviously
even i as somebody who went through that
[ __ ] yeah like i i still fall for it
right you threw out all your ricky
martin cities yeah
i got rid of all my ricky martin cds i
don't know i guarantee you yeah i
guarantee you you buy them again once
you do that
yeah i mean i'm real gay
i'm the captain of the first team all
game guys
i'm crazy i did still see guys i'm
living the video not afraid of death
anymore and i am cut crazy all the new
neurons all gay that's right
all right this one
i thought dude because who's who's
bringing this
dog off the [ __ ] yeah there's some
amazing
middle of the race dude the dog just
wanders in i mean dumb dog too but like
the owner you don't have model you're at
the tour de france
oh hell though so oh hell no that guy
trap they're all crashing
oh [ __ ] no the dumbass dog also the
dumbass owner unless it's a destroyer
combo of both right that's yeah hey
dogged up let's start going to the road
awareness right
i gotta be honest my cat would never do
that'll ruin your hormones
how would you hear those bikes coming
that would be scary yeah cat would also
jump in like matrix over the bikes all
right
but how pissed would you be the first
guy to hit the dog you're like really oh
it's only the biggest bike race in the
world right right i've tried really
a dog
there's no leash law around here
also why is your dog there dude yeah he
doesn't enjoy it like unless you're a
blind man
well yeah and even though you have it on
your hand you know there would be a
harness around that dog i feel like
so we can we can rule out that
possibility what else you got here we go
i don't know what sesame place yes okay
so check it out it's like a little
yeah it's a like an amusement park uh
sesame place philadelphia is facing
backlash is it associated with sesame
street
yes it is and really it comes down i
think you see a lot of these things
where it's like projected racism right
so this in the clip if you don't mind
playing that i can watch this one
um
now so the little black girls go and he
goes
high fives and
what he goes like this and like this but
if you notice he goes like this before
he gets them apparently
a lady was either trying to take a
picture with their kid or like hold the
kid up and he's like i can't he didn't
actually sweat so you guys
yeah but then why did he but but he did
do this to the children they said he
high-fived white kids and not the black
kids yeah apparently there's other
evidence of the mascots doing this at
sesame street interesting i didn't read
that part of the big game
all the time
yeah
yeah from the suit oh my god whoever's
in this i'm not saying big bird people
the sesame place but it's harder to
catch
the lips moving yeah big bird drops the
end but i think he was probably it
looked like big birds are racist
suck yeah one of these interesting
things where people go hard in the paint
i think it was what was it uh kelly
was it the former member of uh destiny's
child tweeting kelly rowland yeah so
she's going hard like i'm not gonna stop
until this there's justice to this but
it's like do you really know though
because
if it's if there's a plausible scenario
in which it wasn't race motivated that
this is i there there are people that
jump on these things
capital that's what they do well also
kelly rowland when
the last time i heard from her right
we're talking about her now
so now she's the face of this movement
let's let's kill big bird and stuff
i always knew snuffaluckas was a racist
you know the the [ __ ] uh oscars the
grouch is a nazi i've heard a million
times
the performer portraying the rosita
character has confirmed that the no hand
gesture seen several times in the video
was not directed any specific person
rather it was a response to multiple
requests for someone in the crowd who
asked rosita to hold their child for a
photo which is not permitted the rosita
performer did not intentionally ignore
the girls as devastated about the
misunderstanding
and he is so lucky that we can't find
his face because he'd be lynched and
hung yeah
we spoke to the family yeah
we apologize these guests for uh not
delivering the experience they expected
we commit to do our best
so kelly rowland's like this is racism
like yeah and if the worst racism your
kid deals with is that
furry mascot that has [ __ ] monkey box
all over it doesn't hold your child
correct and also i was looking at the
eye line she's looking up here the kids
are tiny
you know you're in these big eye like
you know what's your line of sight in a
huge costume like that i wonder if you
can my only issue with is he did
high-five the white kid
and then before right now goes up here
and it's walking and maybe that's your
job and like
maybe the first day you're making sure
to you know shake every kid's hands
that's ridiculous how long has rosita
been working there
a year
you're a little jaded by your own job
aren't you so silly let's watch it in
slow-mo hey here's the other thing
sesame street needs all the good press
they can get my kids don't give a [ __ ]
about sesame street i try to make it let
them watch it to learn something for
once they're like right they don't go
like dude put on a [ __ ] pixar movie
yeah
you're not [ __ ] with pixelated
genius when you have just puppets
puppets just the kids my kid looks at
elm and he's like this is [ __ ] try
competing with 3d now my son's doing
that wait until the metaverse comes
popping daddy lord
it's around the corner
sesame street's like god damn it we're
fighting in the news but for all the
wrong reasons correct
a racist guy you're all right
why no
but joe coy and chelsea and were dating
and everyone loved it it was awesome
i did
it was an adorable love story because
they know each other forever but then
the movie out right now go see it easter
sunday yep go see it
she's in it can't call me for a cameo
that's whatever both great people i just
but i i love chelsea i've known her a
long time but
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i love joe joe is my favorite okay
so we love jungkook's attention in the
room between camp joe and camp chelsea a
little bit i'm camp joe here but it
seems like it ended i like them both
i've just known them both for so long
yeah
but chelsea i think for chelsea she's
getting older how old is chelsea and
she's six maybe 50 something it's not
you know it's like you make these
choices and it's tough you get lonely
when you get to a certain 47 yeah yeah
on joe's 5151 he's older much older but
remember joe got his start on chelsea
lately yeah he was very famous on that
and also remember chelsea has great
shaped natural boobs so
even as a woman ages if she can maintain
that she'll have plenty of options
good point
she's also very smart very funny
what else you got chad um how many you
guys want she'll give us one more let me
okay here i have one here mike tyson
thinks he's going to die really soon i
think we all do mike tyson believes at
all times uh that his fate is imminent
on his podcast hopbox with mike tyson
the former heavyweight boxing champ had
therapist sean mcfarland who specializes
in trauma and addiction on as a guest
and told him he feels he's inching
closer to death we're all gonna die one
day of course tyson said then when i
look in the mirror i see those little
spots on my face i say wow that means my
expiration date is coming close really
we're like bananas
he's also on shrooms every day so like
that as you were saying that but he's
also lived a rough life yeah i think
that you know i think all big guys think
ran die early but um i do as well
but um
i do find it curious like what uh
what
a
how would you say what a [ __ ]
how joe rogan has changed the podcast
game because
i think about joe has all these people
on right and it's all like you learn
some stuff like that like i don't think
mike tyson's having a therapist on if
rogan didn't kind of set that platform
for these interesting conversations like
he's like like he's such a leader in the
industry where people are like oh i want
to introduce
a conversation fighter and a therapist
because it seems like a mismatch but
that's why people tune into jared it's
like well let me hear you talk to the
interesting thing i mean
we've been doing this ten years if
our first
four years if you're in chairman like
hey let's have a therapist on but get
the [ __ ] out who'd want to hear that
we'd be silly talk about dicks and
sucking each other off
people wouldn't go for it right but
rogan's had all and all these scientists
and experts and all this stuff and
people like actually people are into it
yeah you know to a certain degree
mike tyson you know in therapist i'm in
he's for an hour tyson's death
tyson's super deep
one of the quotes i thought was
interesting so he says tyson has become
very philosophical at 56 you become
introspective and before addressing his
mortality he spoke about how money does
not bring the happiness and security
that those who have never had it might
suspect and his quote was
money don't mean [ __ ] to me
i always tell people to think money's
going to make them happy they've never
had money before when you have a lot of
money you could you can't expect nobody
to love it it doesn't bring you hold on
it doesn't bring you inner happiness it
makes your life easier that's what money
does which can make money
it checks off a box that you're not
stressed out about the next meal or car
housing for you yeah and schooling right
and all that stuff is good but as far as
inner happiness money ain't the answer
yeah it has nothing to do with it yeah
joe
what's this joe wrote it's just a pulse
of podcast comments
uh oh this is variety okay uh about
shooting homeless people stuns la on
house advocates what's he what did he
say let's just play the clip it was with
him and segura
they got in trouble too and then we're
on the outside and there's porta potties
not one either like full
i'm assuming
tom said maybe someone has a car parked
there
on the sidewalk like partly on the
sidewalk so they're like half blocking a
lane and then they have like a canopy
draped over their car and they have just
stacks of [ __ ] and then next to it was a
dresser they had a dresser jesus so they
had their shoes and a shoe rack there
was a shoe rack like this is where they
live that's really wild
i didn't know also that
um
you know when when you see stuff like
that on the streets at least in los
angeles or maybe in california those are
that's protected property yeah by the
law you know
like if you were so you're not supposed
to do that they've changed the world but
and but like that's that person's
property by law
even the [ __ ] is protected yes
absolutely you can't move if you were to
go and try to move that or take that
you'd get arrested yeah
yeah hilarious mm-hmm but they wouldn't
ask you if you shot somebody
maybe you should just go and shoot the
homeless people i like your ideas yeah
yeah oh weird names hold on what is
there anything about violent crime in
l.a anymore oh positive jokes that's the
making but hold on
so this [ __ ] guy who blasts us out
wants to [ __ ] on tom and rogan nothing
like a couple rich [ __ ] sitting around
smoking cigars criticizing people with
the rock bottom and that last time they
should shoot homeless people
hold on you're talking about two
high-level comedians that were talking
about a serious situation do you think
he's trying to make thompson girl laugh
do you think joe rogan for one instance
is actually considering that we shoot
anybody he's also he's also making a
comment on how
in la they aren't prosecuting a lot of
violent
it crimes that was his main point
uh gascon
who's getting recalled he's getting
recalled i hope he does he will how is
that going i'd love to see him get
recalled but with this guy they did in
san francisco with chesapeake yes she
[ __ ] he got recalled and then that
woman who came in fired up everybody
that anyone anyone who purged a purge
sir she came home i was like hold on you
did you defended all that stuff all you
were out get the [ __ ] out of here that's
what you got to do garcon's next dum-dum
but these people that want to jump on
this like this guy clearly did this for
retweets and the woke be like yeah let's
get him that's that's the far right
trump guy right this narrative on rogan
you got to be a [ __ ]
if he would have put man uh i've clearly
rogan's joking but it suggests shooting
homeless is a little
too much for me
okay that's fine but to cut that clip
and make it he seems like saying no he's
not he's saying it's so ridiculous
you could shoot them
and you would be less like you get in
trouble than if you moved there yes that
was his point and it's also one high
level comic talk another high level
comic about a serious situation clearly
trying to make him laugh and bring light
because they do they've talking for
three hours yes it's called podcast you
know what it's called entertainment yes
so [ __ ] off
but we know this
let me see yeah
the enemy here is sesame street
and racism that's not either so she
wants she got voted sexist woman on the
planet on uh maxim i think it is max i'm
still around the sexiest woman alive and
you know she's like very she gets she
goes viral on social media at least her
instagram post because she's like super
hot and she does golf yeah dude can i
get some more pictures of her yeah just
have her instagram up too just see you
guys
i do i don't want to get you know i want
to make sure i want to throw any
misinformation right and also not to say
that she isn't sexy but when i open my
explore page on instagram i see about 50
identical women to her as well i don't
like are they playing golf
no she's a professional golfer though
yeah oh she's trying what i don't know
if she's a pro but she's definitely like
a yeah you're using that
well no because you know why she's pro
just hold on cause she makes money hold
up are you a pro if you make money
playing golf yes i would pay her all the
money to play golfing you know you're
right you're right she could put those
tits into my house you are making a good
[ __ ] that is a definition of
professional
though money so yeah chin's a
professional
audio engineer gets paid for it
no she's uh lovely gorgeous yeah she's
lovely yeah i'm not going to argue if
she's not the top hottest i mean are
there no potters i i don't know
she's up there also age
i'm sorry beauty's in the either behind
her yeah but no i think she's extremely
beautiful now sports illustrated look at
this thing goes ugh let's see your
stroke right yeah let me seriously what
do you want her to do
i want to see her stroke you want to see
her struggle stroke uh her strut yes
i think she's like what is she going to
do mountain range i like the mountain
range let's see i'll tell you if she's
good
boom
looks good could have kept our head down
hey god damn it staunch underscore em
francis
juicy [ __ ]
so aggressive come on buckaroo god damn
honor take that to reddit they're kids
here
yeah she's pretty cool
yeah i would watch golf if she was like
that do you know how big women's golf
would be if she was like tiger what's
good golfer though
she's not i think she just does it yeah
she just does it well she does it very
well brad now i like your attitude no i
i like her she just plays basketball or
i appreciate her outfits is the thing
brent
that the glasses the who's her man tight
outfit
look at that situation tis the season
uh new blackjack wood set oh i bet they
paid all the money for this she has how
many followers three point five yeah
three point five how much my dumbass
gets and i don't look like her she gets
all the money to pop
let's see if she's with someone steve
god damn it stephen 2018
steve tanoco oh that's him right there
not sure who that is but he's a baseball
guy and he
white says yes divorce separated be
there's still hope for you guys there
you go
yeah she's pretty uh
easy on the eyes
she sure is buddy easy on the eyes i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna tweet at uh
maxim and
complain all right buddy well we did it
again we did it again again now your boy
has hit the road i'm headed downtown to
announce the partnership between thick
boy
fight uh studio and one championship
we're gonna be the official
outlet for one championship i like to
announce the press conference today so
while you guys are watching this i'm
probably at the press conference great
um and then
as this comes out you might make it los
angeles hollywood improv there are 15
tickets left we have jaisal nick anthony
jeselnik trevor wallace jeff dye eric
griffin and myself
all at the hollywood improv tonight at
10 p.m so get your tickets there and
then tomorrow night thursday friday
saturday i'm in san diego laugh factory
san diego july 21st through the 23rd
then august 4th through the 6th is
baltimore chicago one show one night
only at the den theater that's a friday
night in chicago at 7 30. um there's a
bunch of other dates on there but
chicago one night only den theater on
the 26th baltimore the fourth through
the six and then san diego europe this
week thursday friday saturday come get
some san diego uh that's it man there it
is uh best of sammy the wool gravano the
second part of that
airs tomorrow at 12 thursday at noon
brookfield wisconsin milwaukee improv um
you're up tomorrow july 21st friday the
22nd and saturday the 23rd i will be
there austin texas the following week in
cap cities
um
july 28 29 30 nashville tennessee zany's
august 26 27
washington spokane comedy club september
22 20. some good dates coming up buddy
oh yeah all right kids we love you this
is the final kid oh real quick update on
fire kid 3d
fox was like no doubt here's the 12
episode in the outtakes i went that's so
cool of you guys very nice of you thanks
for pulling this off pete who used to
work at fox sports and then fox is such
a big uh machine they went oh we forgot
to pull the episodes from our youtube
and our fox channels and we've made it
so you can't post them so they're
working on that right now and hopefully
by next monday you're getting or next
tuesday you're getting the new fire in
the kid 3d episodes all 12 of them and
the outtakes one a week so 12 week span
of all the episodes so i'm dealing with
it now kids i'm on it though love you
guys all right we're out